all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag info davidpackman.com for
questions comments concerns suggestions
all of it and of course occasionally a
tweet or a Facebook message or a YouTube
comment might make it into this segment
we love all of it uh let's start today
with some criticisms some criticisms
which I am I'm glad to issue Corrections
when I make mistakes I'm glad to give a
sampling of comments from people that
aren't thrilled with me uh David wrote
in and said you were out there dude
Trump was and maybe will be again the
best thing that's happened to this
country in decades open your eyes your
radio cast must be funded by the demo
rats no the demo rats and the demon rats
and the Democrats none of them fund the
show George Soros doesn't fund the show
whoever else you imagine is funding the
show doesn't fund the show the show's
funded most by our audience and then by
a few advertisers that's that's kind of
what it is
um the uh I guess all I can say is
congratulations for using the correct
your the correct form of your all right
so David is waiting around for the
return of trump almost uh in like a
weird Messianic way it's very very
interesting next to criticism is from
Don Don wrote in and said you are a
freaking idiot take your liberal Marxist
socialistic garbage somewhere else it's
idiots like you that are destroying this
country the oligarchies are bringing
this that's oligarchy apostrophe s are
bringing this country down and should
they succeed you won't mean crap to them
then let's see how you will put food on
your table pay your mortgage and charge
your defunct grid system car you don't
know crap and are just as stupid as the
rest of your Democratic constituents
well a really strong condemnation
uh by dawn of a political ideology that
I don't hold I I'm not a Marxist or a
socialist but maybe go find a Marxist or
a socialist and criticize them I don't
know it's always weird they seem
confused uh Matt wrote in about
interviews with the so-called radical
left Matt says David sir just listen to
your explanation of how right-wing
candidates may or may not end up on your
show for interviews and it made me
wonder if there are any left-wing
candidates that you might consider
radical or unreasonable in some of their
views and if you'd be interested in
interviewing them perhaps there aren't
any and it is purely a disease of the
Republican party I wouldn't be surprised
but I'd be interested in your take
either way yeah I mean listen there are
extreme leftists the the difference is
the extreme leftists don't ever seem to
win their Democratic primaries and one
of the things we do on this show because
we can't turn the show into the you know
ninth congressional district show where
we interview everybody running for the
Democratic nomination and everybody
running for the Republican nomination we
tend to wait until after primaries to do
these interviews as a practical matter
and the Republicans will often vote for
the wackiest in the primary and so
that's who I end up interviewing
Democrats rarely vote for the super
wacky extreme left Winger
um and so by the time they get to me
there's been a sorting already and much
the same way that Trump would never have
won the Democratic Primary in 2016. a
lot of the so-called radical left that
Matt is referring to in his email
don't pass that first filter and that's
why they don't end up on the show but I
have no opposition in principle to
speaking to anybody uh Robert Rhoden
this is very interesting and this
relates to Roe v Wade and abortion and
other things we've been talking about
Robert says big fan of the show
appreciate your rational approach to
controversial subjects I wanted to write
to you about abortion people are
unfortunately but legally making
end-of-life decisions all the time when
an individual's higher brain function
ceases the family can opt to have life
support suspended this is generally
rationalized by the collective
understanding that once higher brain
functions have ended the person is
already gone if people have accepted and
this is the wrong accepted okay so the
the right word here is ACC this is the
but let's imagine we understand what
Robert is saying if people have accepted
that this is the way things are then why
can't the opposite be true if your life
ends when your higher brain function
stops then why would your beginning of
Life be before your higher frame brain
function begins my understanding is that
dreaming is supposed to begin in the
third trimester if I'm not mistaken this
should signify the beginnings of thought
and the brains need to process them so
there's a couple issues here first of
all Robert is completely correct and
there's actually another aspect to this
which is
quote other people
make decisions about
end of life all the time as you're
talking about in situations where
people's brain function has stopped or
in lots of different situations
including hospice type situations
why couldn't the same decisions be made
when a fetus has no brain function and
isn't going to so in these most extreme
cases where Republicans want women
carrying non-viable fetuses to term why
is it okay to make those decisions for
others later and not earlier aside from
the personhood question but there's kind
of a bigger issue here which is you're
never going to convince the right on
abortion with arguments like this
because they will say well we don't care
about brain function we care about
heartbeat and that's where the heartbeat
bills come from and then you'd say well
okay but what about this and they'll say
now We Believe life begins at conception
and it's an endless loop and so while
these types of questions that Robert
brings up are super interesting and
they're accurate and they're relevant
that's not going to convince the most
Ardent anti-choicers on the right sadly
I wish we could talk sense with them but
unfortunately we can't Sean wrote in
about my interview with that Republican
candidate Allison Hayden who's running
against our friend Eric swalwell and
Sean says to David whoever whomever I
enjoy all of David's interviews I find
them fascinating and informative but I
think my favorite type of interview is
when David speaks to Republicans who
seem to be confused by facts versus
their opinion needless to say I was
glued to your discussion with Allison
Hayden as per the usual I think David
did a great job but there's one question
I would love to hear him ask of these
people if Trump would have won the
presidency would they still be making
such a big deal out of the legitimacy
and security of our elections guys we
all know the answer to that of course
they wouldn't
if Trump had won the electoral vote or
the electoral vote and the popular vote
they would be doing what they did in
2016 which is saying sort of like there
was some fraud
and my real victory was even bigger but
they would not be filing 60 70 Court
complaints of course they wouldn't be
doing any of those things don't believe
for a second that this is some kind of
moral fight for them it's just about
their guy lost that's all they care
about
Daniel wrote in about my Republican
guests
and says David after hearing your
interview yesterday with the Northern
California Republican candidate that was
Allison Hayden and after hearing several
other recent videos interviews I have an
honest inquiry as to whether you seek
out the worst Republican candidates to
interview or if you're just shooting
fish in a barrel do you specifically
Target The Crazies or are you just
giving us a sampling of what the
Republican party has generally become
love you're taking them to task though
and trying desperately to make them
think about the word salad they're
spewing so last week we had a voicemail
asking a similar question my colleague
John has been heading up these
interviews he has interviewed I want to
say close to 50 different Republican
candidates some of them don't even
respond some of them do but then they
find out about how interviews are
conducted here and that real questions
will be asked and then they say I'm not
interested or they stop responding some
will agree to come on and then once we
schedule it we'll never hear from them
again some confirm the interview
literally hours before it's scheduled
and then they just never show up on
Skype and we never hear from them again
we cast a wide net
some of them are less crazy like that
guy Johnny T guy interviewed I still
disagree with him about just about
everything but he was less overtly
Bonkers and less cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
but we are casting a wide net we're not
targeting the whack jobs but a lot of
them are really wacky and it's just a
representation of who's running in that
party right now
um I the zombie plail
wrote in and said David you should sit
back and think about why right Wingers
around the world are performing better
than ever people are very angry at their
politicians yeah it's I think the
implication here is the left has done so
terribly that globally and really they
mean like Western Europe and to some
degree but the Americas voters are going
to right Wingers
what's going on is that
parties on both sides anecdotally have
failed voters in lots of parts of the
world but the real change has been
the echo Chambers created by social
media and modern media which allow
really
stupid quite frankly ideas primarily on
the non-science right to get repetition
that they wouldn't otherwise get we've
talked before if Nixon had had Fox News
and Facebook
it's not clear Nixon would have actually
ended up resigning and it's possible he
would have been impeached by the house
and maybe not convicted by the Senate if
Senators at that time had seen support
in social media the way there was
support for Trump during the impeachment
trials that he had so I do think that a
lot of this is thanks to disinformation
uh faux populist messages or maybe
actual populist messages which don't
really lead to any substantive policy
have also kind of infected the political
discussion and so it's not about the
left has been so bad that right-wingers
have won that's it's not that at all but
there is a story there to be told and I
think it's an important one for sure
uh all right if you have any questions
comments concerns things you want to say
write to info at davidpackman.com your
email may be featured on an upcoming
episode and remember that the party
doesn't have to end right now you can
sign up on my website joinpakman.com to
get an extra show every day that's the
bonus show and so many more great member
benefits you can use the coupon code
indict i n d i c t to save a bundle off
of the cost of a membership we'll see
you on the bonus show or otherwise back
here on Monday